entertaining season might be upon us
but I think casual cravings
and late night bites
are appropriate year round
now I've got nine Huntly and Palmers
cracker combos that you might wanna save for later
for whatever occasion it is that you're catering for
For casual cravings on the Baked Sourdough
which is made was real sourdough culture
by the way
you might wanna try Marmite
smashed avocado and chilli flakes
Caramelised Onion Flatbread lends itself to a
simple hummus and tomato medley
and you can have the Sprouted Rye cracker bread
whole or quartered
and I've topped mine with basil pesto and brie
now imagine you've got some people over
and you want them to think that you're
classier than you actually are
which is something I do quite often
you might offer them some Baked Sourdough with pesto
Pear, rocket, Gruyère and balsamic glaze
maybe some heirloom tomatoes topped with burrata
fresh basil and balsamic glaze again
because I really can't fault it
maybe a small bite on the Sprouted Rye
with some whipped feta
caramelised onion honey and fresh thyme
might be more your cup of tea
and I don't know about you
but I find my cracker cravings hit me when
I probably should be asleep
just trust me on this one
but almond butter
thin slices of apple and cinnamon is the perfect late night treat
maybe you want something a bit sweeter with cream cheese
Berry coulis and shaved dark chocolate
Or - and this one feels much fancier
than it actually is
but mascarpone, honey and thyme
It’s mostly sweet with a subtle salt
and it's quick and delicious
now I'm curious if I was gonna offer you any of these
which plate are you choosing?
cause I think the Huntley & Palmer's range
is perfect for every occasion